jetzt geht es um den
tsg 2 patricia sagt uns einmal was
dahinter steckt es gibt gut lesen wie
also eigentlich wollte bild reporter
karl keine filmaufnahmen vom teil könige
machen und der teig kündigte ist
wahnsinnig gerne in bayern ist gerade
auch in münchen nur mit einer ganz
kleinen belegschaft von 250 menschen um
ihn herum sind ja aber das haste dem
teig könig so gar nicht dass er da
gefilmt wird auf wir sagen ganz
öffentlichem gelände also nicht irgendwo
in seinen privaträumen der ausgang des
ganzen also eine bedrohung unseres
reporters durch die thailändischen
sicherheitsleute und es ging sogar so
weit dass die polizei kommen musste
ärger mit dem könig das passiert ich zum
ersten mal das thailändische
landesoberhaupt das ist ja mancher sagen
längst
skandalnudel
könig macher von thailand wo er
auftaucht sind neue schlagzeilen nicht
weit maha vajiralongkorn
69 jahre alt seid 2016 auf dem thron und
der reichste monarch der welt
geschätztes vermögen 100 milliarden euro
vorlieben bauchfreie extravagante lux
und bayern ja genau in deutschland lebt
der teig könig nämlich deutlich lieber
als in seinem eigenen land zum
missfallen seines volkes aber nun ja
neues drama soll einfach kein fan vom
thailändischen klima seien und deshalb
mietet er gerne mal das gesamte gran
hotel sonnenbichl in garmisch
partenkirchen und besitzt am starnberger
see natürlich zusätzlich noch eine
pompöse villa stets an seiner seite
königin sofia und seit 2009 10 auch die
geliebte co die im übrigen trotz vieler
verbot zur zweistündigen ernannt werden
soll und der 2020 sogar ein ganzes
flugzeug in den vorgarten stellte rama
ix ein könig der neben seinem adelstitel
auch noch einen skandal titel verdient
hätte klar solche skurrilen
shoppingcenter aufnahmen in kropp
gehören dazu und irritiert darf man sich
sicherlich auch über das verhältnis des
dreikönigs zu hunden zeigen achtung kein
scherz sein pudel 5 uhr wurde in den
rang eines luftwaffen generals erhoben
und nur in gala-uniform gassi geführt
so und der clinch mit dem king ja und
unserem reporter karl keim den haben uns
jetzt mal genauer an essen sie mich
jetzt so geschaltet nicht der qingdao
unser interne ging herr kalkan bei uns
was war denn da los bei deiner
begegnungen mit dem teig du dich
ja ich hab im sechs stunden lang
gewartet um dieses eine foto zu
erhaschen oder diese videos aufzunehmen
das ist ja immer sehr sehr schwierig
diesen könig dann wirklich vor die
kamera zu kriegen er ist am montag
gelandet in münchen und hat sich im
hilton hotel airport was viele sehr
wahrscheinlich kennen vom sport 1
doppelpass da niedergelassen hat da
mehrere etagen gemietet und ja und dann
irgendwann so gegen 16 uhr 50
da ich an einem hotel lift dass sich da
oben so drei generell auf jeden fall
sein die so aus die hatten der sehr viel
wie man das tor aus amerikanischen
filmen kennen so sehr viele abzeichen
daran dass die spalier gestanden haben
an einem lift in der vierten etage und
dann habe ich mir gedacht hier passiert
jetzt gleich irgendwas dann wurde der
fahrstuhl blockiert und dann ging es
runter ins untergeschoss das ist so ein
unterirdischer weg der dann so zwischen
so parcours der verbindet der dann gehe
dann zum pool bereich geht der führt
aber durch öffentliches gebiet denn da
unten sind auch parkhäuser und da habe
ich ihn dann fotografiert und gefilmt
und dann gegen der spaß richtig los der
reist der mit einer entourage von 250
leuten natürlich sind diese
sicherheitsmitarbeiter natürlich bis
unter die kinnlade bewaffnet der
hoteldirektor kam auf mich zu und dann
ist es sie gehen hier nirgendwo hin ich
fühlte mich jetzt nicht bedroht um mein
leben so weit will ich nicht gehen aber
es ist schon ein mulmiges gefühl wenn
dann plötzlich 20 leute um einen herum
stehen und man wurde fotografiert und
gefilmt und hat natürlich kein bock dass
diese menschen jetzt zu meinem auto
folgen und sah mich dann gezwungen die
polizei zu rufen die dieses thema dann
aber auch relativ schnell abgeräumt hat
man hat dem hotelchef dann erklärt dass
es sich um öffentlichen bereich handelt
und dass der dass der teig könig eine
person des öffentlichen lebens ist und
dann hat mich die polizei noch zu meinem
auto begleitet mit der begründung dass
mir auch wirklich niemand folgt also da
muss man sich mal kompliment auch an die
polizei richten das ist ihren job den
haben sie hervorragend gemacht das war
ein mulmiges gefühl tatsächlich muss ich
muss ich ehrlich aber die zu geben als
polizeireporter habe schon viele heikle
szenen erlebt aber so was ist dann immer
schon noch ein bisschen was anderes wenn
dann die ganze entourage von dem teig
könig mit dabei ist und man wird gefilmt
und fotografiert ja das ist eigentlich
so keine aufnahmen natürlich die dann in
thailand für großen wirbel sorgen ja
aber sind dann ich bin gut aus der sache
raus gekommen jetzt war hier gerade die
dänische königin margarethe in berlin zu
besuch war angela merkel da konnte man
einfach ein foto machen von den beiden
und man musste auch keine sorge haben
dass ein irgendeine dänische
sicherheitsleute auf den hals gehetzt
werden warum ist das dabei dem teig
könig anders warum treibt er sich hier
überhaupt rum das war jetzt kein
staatsbesuch immer wieder da irgendwie
im süden deutschlands diesmal eben in
münchen und warum muss man angst vor
seinen leuten haben hier in deutschland
ja das ist das große das ist das große
problem die vor allen dingen seine
außenwirkung die kommt in thailand gar
nicht gut an im vergangenen jahr war er
monatelang in garmisch-partenkirchen in
dem hotel sonnenbichl als er corona auch
in thailand grassierte sein vater
bhumipol der war sehr beliebt aber er
kommt bei dem volk gar nicht gut an und
auch diese diese aufnahmen die wir da
gesehen haben aus möbelhäusern oder wie
er da halb nackt aus einer s klasse
mercedes s klasse steigt in seinem
privatjet in seine flugzeuge das kommt
in thailand gar nicht gut an und wenn
man den könig in thailand beleidigt da
drohen dann auch bis zu 15 jahre haft
für majestätsbeleidigung und solche
bilder will
will der thailändische könig einfache
verhindern der hat keinen bock darauf
dass diese bilder um die welt gehen denn
die menschenrechtsaktivitäten da die
menschenrechte in thailand sind alles
andere als eher gut so wie mir dass wir
bei uns kennen man will das unter allen
umständen verhindern dass er bilder von
diesen mann auftauchen wie der in
opulenten luxus stil hier in münchen und
in bayern lebt wie gesagt wenn man das
sieht mal vorstellt das ist total absurd
was in diesem hotel abgeht dann müssen
mitarbeiter von ihm ich habe das gesehen
wie sie da die ganzen pudel gassi führen
die tragen da das muss man sich
vorstellen wie so ein kleiner
ameisenstaat die tragen stühle und
tische reihen und fahren große
gepäckkoffer raus mit paketen in die
autos rein raus schwarze mercedes
limousinen sowie toso etwas größere
autos und diese bilder möchte man
einfach nicht dass diese bilder um die
welt gehen und das steckt dahinter dass
man dann natürlich auch journalisten
auch angeht und auch unter druck setzen
will ich hatte mich davon nicht beirren
lassen und habe dann einfach
weitergemacht aber bevor wir die dik ii
tatsächlich diese leute auch folgen zu
meinem auto und dann man denkt über der
weise einen komischen unfall hat oder so
dachte ich ich rufe lieber mal die
polizei die das dann sehr schnell gelöst
hat kalkar im in münchen vielen
herzlichen dank